so that takes us to quake
what was the leap
there
what was some fascinating technical
challenges and there were a lot or not
challenges but innovations that you've
come up with so quake was kind of the
first thing where i did have to kind of
come face to face with my limitations
where it was the first thing where i
really did kind of
give it my all and still come up a
little you know come up a little bit
short in terms of what and when i wanted
to to get it done and the company ran
had some serious stresses through the
the whole project and
we uh we bit off a lot so the things
that we set out to do was it was going
to be really a true 3d engine where it
could do six degree of freedom you could
have all the all the viewpoints you
could model anything it had
a really remarkable new lighting model
with the the surface caching and things
that was one of those where it was
starting to to do some things that they
weren't doing even on the very high end
systems
um and it was going to be completely
programmable uh in the modding
standpoint where the thing that you
couldn't do in doom you could replace
almost all of the media but you couldn't
really change the game uh there were
still some people that were doing the
hex editing of the executable the
d-hacked things where you could change a
few things about rules and people made
some early capture of the flag type
things by hacking the executable but it
wasn't really set out to do that quake
was going to have its own programming
language that the game was going to be
implemented in it and that would be able
to be overwritten just like any of the
media code was going to be data for that
and you would be able to have expansion
packs that changed fundamental things
and mods and so on
and the
the multiplayer was going to be playable
over the internet it was going to
support a client server rather than
peer-to-peer so we had the possibility
of supporting larger numbers of players
in disparate locations with this full
flexibility of the the programming
overrides with full six degree of
freedom modeling and viewing and with
this fancy new light mapped um kind of
surface caching side it was a lot and
this was one of those things that if i
could go back and tell um you know tell
younger me to do something differently
it would have been to split those
innovations up into two phases in two
separate games will be phase one and
phase two so it probably would have been
taking the doom rendering engine and
bringing in uh the tcp uh client server
focusing on the multiplayer and the uh
the quake c or would have been doom c
programming language there so i would
have split that into programming
language and networking with the same
doom engine rather than forcing
everybody to go towards the the pen you
know the quake engine which really meant
getting a pentium you know while it ran
on a 486 it was not a great experience
there we could have made more people
happier and gotten two games done in 50
more time hi so speaking of people
happier our
mutual friend joe rogan it seems like
his the the most important uh moment of
his life is uh centered around quake so
it was a definitive um
part of his life so would he agree with
your
uh thinking that they should split
uh so he is a person who loves quake and
played quake a lot
would he agree that you should have done
the doom engine with and focus on the
multiplayer for phase one
uh or
in your looking back it is is the the 3d
world that quake created
was also fundamental to the the
environment
you know i would say that what would
have happened is
you would have had a
a doom looking but quake feeling uh game
eight months earlier and then maybe six
months after quake actually shipped then
there would have been the full running
auto pentium um six degree of freedom
graphics engine type things there so
it's not that it wouldn't have it
wouldn't have been there it would have
been something amazingly cool earlier
and then something even cooler somewhat
later
where i would much rather in have gone
and done two one-year development
efforts i
cycle them through i be a little more
pragmatic about that rather than killing
us ourselves on the whole quake
development but i say it's obviously
things worked out well in the end but
looking back and saying how would i
optimize and do things differently that
did seem to be a clear case where
i going ahead and we had enormous
momentum on doom you know we did doom 2
as the kind of commercial boxed version
after our shareware success with the
original but we could have just made
another doom game adding those new
features in it would have been huge we
would have learned all the same lessons
but faster and it would have given six
degree of freedom and pentium class
systems a little bit more time to get
mainstream because we did cut out a lot
of people with the hardware requirements
for quake
was there any dark moments for you
personally psychologically in having
um
in um having such harsh deadlines and
having to solve so many difficult
technical challenges
so i've never really had
really dark black places i mean i i
can't necessarily put myself in anyone
else's shoes but i understand a lot of
people
have
you know have significant challenges
with kind of their their mental health
and well-being and i've been i've been
super stressed i've been you know
unhappy as a teenager in various ways
but i've never
i've never really gone to
a very dark place i just seem to be
largely immune to what really wrecks
people i mean i've had plenty of time
when i'm very unhappy and miserable
about something but it's never hit me
like you know i believe it winds up
hitting some other people i've borne up
well under whatever stresses have i
you know have kind of fallen on me and
i've always coped best on that when all
i need to do is is usually just kind of
bear down on my work i i pull myself out
of whatever hole i might be slipping
into by actually making progress
i i mean maybe if i was in a position
where i was never able to make that
progress i could have slid down further
but i've always been in a place where
okay a little bit more work maybe i'm in
a tough spot here but i i always know if
i just keep pushing eventually i break
through and i make progress i feel good
about what i'm doing
i am and that's been enough for me so
far in my life have you seen in in the
distance
uh like um
you know ideas of depression or
contemplating suicide have you seen
those things far so it was interesting
when when i was a teenager i was you
know i i was probably on some level a
troubled youth i was unhappy most of my
teenaged you know years i you know i
really i wanted to be on my own doing
programming all the time i you know as
soon as i was 18 19 even though i was
poor i was doing exactly what i wanted
and i was very happy but high school was
not a great time for me and i i had a
conversation with like the school
counselor and they're kind of running
their script it's like okay it's kind of
a weird kid here let's carefully probe
around it's like you know do you ever
think about ending it all i'm like no of
course not never not at all i this is
temporary things are going to be better
i'm
and and that's always been kind of the
case for me and obviously that's not
that way for everyone and other people
do react differently and
what was your um what was your escape
from the troubled youth like uh
you know
music
video games
books
how did you escape from a world that's
full of cruelty and suffering and that's
absurd yeah i mean i i was not you know
i was not victim of cruelty and
suffering it's like i was an unhappy
somewhat petulant youth and you know in
my point where i you know i'm not
putting myself up with anybody else's
suffering but i was unhappy objectively
and i the things that i i did that very
much characterized my childhood were i
had um books comic books dungeons and
dragons arcade games video games like
some of my my fondest childhood memories
are the convenience stores the 7-elevens
and quick trips because they had a
spinner rack of comic books and they had
a little side room with two or three
video games arcade games in it and that
was uh that was very much my happy place
you know if i could i get my comic books
and uh if i could go to a library and
you know go through those the little
zero zero zero section where computer
books were supposed to be and there are
a few sad little books there but still
just being able to sit down and go
through that and i read you know i read
a ridiculous number of books both
fiction and non-fiction as a teenager
and i you know as i my rebel my
rebelling in high school was just
sitting there with my nose in a book
ignoring the class and through lots of
it and teachers had a range of reactions
to that some more uh more accepting of
it than others
i'm with you on that so let us return to
quake for a bit with the technical
challenges what what um
everything together from the from the
networking to the the graphics what what
are some things you remember that were
that were innovations yet to come up
with in order to make it all happen yeah
so there were a bunch of things on quake
where on the one hand the idea that i
built my own programming language to
implement the game in
looking back and i try to tell people
it's like every every high level
programmer sometime in their career goes
through and they invent their own
language it just seems to be a thing
that's pretty broadly done people
they're like i'm gonna go write a
computer programming language and
i
you know i don't regret having done it
but after that i switched from quake c
my quirky little
pseudo object orienter entity oriented
language there quake 2 went back to
using dlls with c and then quake 3 i
implemented my own c interpreter or
compiler which was a much smarter thing
to do that i should have done originally
for quake but building my own language
was an experience i learned a lot from
that i am and then there was a
generation of game programmers that
learned programming with quake c which i
feel kind of bad about because you know
i mean we give javascript a lot of crap
but i'm you know quake c was nothing to
write home about there
uh but it was it allowed people to do
magical things you get into programming
not because you love the
you know
the bnf syntax of a language it's
because the language lets you do
something that you cared about and
here's very much you could do something
in a whole beautiful three-dimensional
world and the idea and the fact that the
code for the game was out there you
could say i like the shotgun but i want
it to be more badass you go in there and
say okay now it does 200 points damage
and then you go around with a big grin
on your face blowing up monsters all
over the game
so yeah it's i you know it is not uh
what i would do today going back with
that language but that was a big part of
it
learning about the networking stuff i
because it's interesting where i learned
these things by reading books so i would
get a book on networking and find
something i read all about and learn
okay packets they can be you know out of
order or lost or duplicated these are
all the things that can theoretically
happen to packets so i wind up spending
all this time thinking about how do we
deal about all that and it turns out of
course in the real world those are
things that yes theoretically can happen
with multiple routes but they really
aren't things that you're 99.99
of your packets have to deal with i am
so there was learning experiences about
uh lots of that and like why when tcp is
appropriate versus udp and and how if
you do things in udp you wind up
reinventing tcp badly in almost all
cases so you know there's there's good
arguments for using both for different
game technology different parts of the
game process transitioning from level to
level and all
but the the graphics were the showcase
of what
what quake was all about it was this
graphics technology that nobody had seen
there
and it was a while before you know there
were competitive things out there and it
went a long time internally really not
working where we were even building
levels where uh the game just was not at
all shippable with large fractions of
the world like disappearing not being
there
or being really slow in various parts of
it and it was this act of faith it's
like i think i'm going to be able to fix
this i think i'm going to be able to
make this work i'm and
lots of stuff changed where the level
designers would build something and have
to throw it away as something
fundamental in the kind of graphics or
level technology change
and
the um so there were two big things that
contributed to making it possible at
that time frame i am two new things
there was certainly hardcore optimized
low-level assembly language this is
where i had hired michael a brash away
from microsoft and he had been one of my
early inspirations where that back in
the soft disk days the library of
magazines that they had
some of my most treasured ones were
michael a brash's uh articles in dr
dobb's journal and it was it was amazing
after all of our success in doom we were
able to kind of hit him up and say hey
we'd like you to come work at id
software and he was in the senior
technical role at microsoft and
i am you know and he was on track for
and this was right when microsoft was
starting to take off and i did
eventually you know convince him that
what we were doing was going to be
really amazing with quake it was going
to it was going to be something nobody
had seen before it had these aspects of
what we were talking about we had
metaverse talk back then we you know we
had read snow crash and we were we knew
about this and uh michael was i was big
into the science fiction and we would
talk about all that and kind of spin
this tale and it was some of the same
conversations that we have today about
the metaverse about how you could have
different areas linked together by
portals and you could have
user-generated content and changing out
all of these things so you really were
creating the metaverse with quake and we
we talked about things like philosophy
you used to be advertised as a virtual
reality experience you know that was the
first wave of virtual reality was in the
late 80s and early 90s you had like the
lawnmower man
you know movie and you had time in
newsweek talking about the early vpl
headsets and of course that cratered so
hard that people didn't want to look at
virtual reality for decades afterwards
where uh it was just it was smoke and
mirrors it was not real in the sense
that you could actually do something
real and valuable with it but uh but
still we had that kind of common set of
talking points and we were talking about
what these games could uh could become
and how you'd like to see people
building all of these creative things
because we were seeing an explosion of
work with doom at that time where people
were doing amazingly cool things like we
saw cooler levels than we had built
coming out of the user community and
then people finding ways to you know
change the the characters in different
ways and it was great and we knew what
we were doing in quake was removing
those last things there was some quirky
things with a couple of the data types
that didn't work right for overriding
and then and then the core thing about
the programming model
and i was definitely going to hit all of
those in quake i'm
but the the graphics side of it was i
was still
i knew what i wanted to do and it was
one of these hubris things where it's
like well so far i've been able to kind
of
kick everything that i set out to go do
uh but quake was definitely a little bit
more than could be comfortably chewed at
that point and i but michael was one of
the
one of the strongest programmers and
graphics programmers that i knew and he
was one of the people that i trusted to
to write assembly code you know better
than i could and there's there's a few
people that i can point to about things
like this where i'm a world-class
optimizer i mean i make things go fast
but i recognize there's a number of
people that can write tighter assembly
code tighter sim decode or tighter cuda
code than you know then i can write i am
you know my best strengths are a little
bit more at the system level i mean i'm
good at all of that but the most
leverage comes from making the decisions
that are a little bit higher up where
you figure out how to change your large
scale problems so that these lower level
problems are easier to do or it makes it
possible to do them in a i'm in a
uniquely fast way so most of my
you know my big wins in a lot of ways
from all the way from the early games
through you know through vr and the
aerospace work that i'm doing and or did
and hopefully the ai work that i'm
working on now is finding an angle on
something that means you trade off
something that you maybe think you need
but it turns out you don't need and by
making a sacrifice in one place you can
get big advantages in another place is
it clear at which level of the system
those big advantages can be gained
it's not always clear and that's why
the thing that that i try to make one of
my core values and i
proselytize to a lot of people is trying
to know the entire stack you know trying
to see through everything that happens
and it's almost impossible on like the
web browser level of things where
there's so many levels to it but you
should at least understand what they all
are even if you can't understand all the
performance characteristics at each
level
but it goes all the way down to
literally the hardware so what does the
what is this chip capable of
and what is this software that you're
writing capable of and then with this
architecture you put on top of that then
the ecosystem around it all the people
that are that are working on it so there
are there are all these decisions and
they're never made in a globally optimal
way but sometimes you can drive a thread
of global optimality through it you
can't look at everything it's too
complicated but sometimes you can step
back up and make a different decision
and we kind of went through this on the
graphics side on quake where
i in some ways it was kind of bad where
michael would spend his time writing
like i'd i'd rough out the basic
routines like okay here's our span
rasterizer and he would spend a month
writing this you know beautiful cycle
optimized i am piece of assembly
language that does you know does what i
asked it to do and he did it faster than
like my original code would do or
probably what i would be able to do even
if i had spent that month on it i but
then we'd have some cases when i'd be
like okay well i figured out at this
higher level instead of drawing these in
a painter's order here i do a span
buffer and it cuts out
30 or 40 of all of these pixels but it
means you need to rewrite kind of this
interface of all of that and i could
tell that war on him a little bit but in
the end it was it was the right thing to
do where we wound up changing that
rasterization approach and we wound up
with a super optimized assembly language
core loop and then a good system around
it which minimized how much that had to
be called and so in order to be able to
do this kind of system level thinking
whether we're talking about
game development
aerospace
nuclear energy
ai
vr you have to be able to understand the
hardware
the low-level
software the high-level software the
design decisions the whole thing the the
full stack of it yeah and that's where a
lot of these things become possible when
you're really when you're bringing the
future forward i mean there's a pace
that everything just kind of glides
towards where we have a lot of progress
that's happening at such a dif so many
different ways you kind of slide towards
progress just left your own programs
just get faster for a while it wasn't
clear if they were gonna get fatter more
than they get quicker than they get
faster and it cancels out but it is
clear now in retrospect no programs just
get faster and have gotten faster for a
long time but if you want to do
something like back at that original
talking about scrolling games say what
this needs to be five times faster well
we can wait six years and just it'll
naturally get that much faster at that
time or you come up with some really
clever way of doing it so there are
those opportunities like that in a whole
bunch of different areas now most
programmers don't need to to be thinking
about that there's not that many
you know there's a lot of opportunities
for this but it's not everyone's work a
day type stuff so everyone doesn't have
to know how all these things work they
don't have to know how their compiler
works how you know the processor chip
manages cache eviction and all these
low-level things but sometimes there are
powerful opportunities that you can look
at and say we can bring the future
five years
faster you know we can do something that
wouldn't it be great if we could do this
well we can do it today if we make a
certain set of decisions and it is in
some ways smoking mirrors where you say
it's like doom was a lot of smoke and
mirrors where people thought it was more
capable than it actually was but we
picked the right smoke and mirrors to
deploy in the game where by doing this
people will think that it's more general
if we are going to amaze them with what
they've got here and they won't notice
that it doesn't do these other things so
smart decision making at that point
that's where that
that kind of global holistic top-down
view uh can work and i'm
i'm really a strong believer that
technology
should be
sitting at that table having those
discussions because you do have cases
where you say well you want to be the
jonathan ivy or whatever where it's a a
pure design solution
and
that's i in some cases now where you
truly have almost infinite resources
like if you're trying to do a scrolling
game on the pc now you don't even have
to talk to a technology person you can
just have i you know any intern can make
that go run as fast as it needs to there
and it can be completely design based
but if you're trying to do something
that's hard either that can't be done
for resources like vr on a mobile
chipset or that we don't even know how
to do yet like artificial general
intelligence it's probably going to be a
matter of coming at it from an angle
like i mean for agi we have some of like
what are some of the hutter principles
about how you can you know acceler uh
some of the there are theoretical ways
that you can say this is the optimal
learning algorithm that can solve
everything but it's completely
impractical you know you just can't do
that so clearly you have to make some
concessions for general intelligence and
nobody knows what the right ones are yet
so people are taking different angles of
attack i hope i've got something clever
to come up with uh in that space
it's been surprising to me and i think
perhaps it is a principle of progress
that smoke and mirrors somehow is the
way you build the future
you kind of
you kind of fake it till you make it and
you almost always make it i think that's
going to be the way we achieve agi
that's going to be the way we build
uh consciousness into our machines is
there's you know philosophers debate
about the touring test
is essentially about faking it till you
make it you start by faking it and i
think that always leads
to making it
because if you look at history arguments
when as soon as people start talking
about qualia and consciousness and
chinese rooms and things it's like i
just check out i just don't think
there's any value in those conversations
it's just like go ahead tell me it's not
going to work i'm going to do my best to
try to make it work anyways
i don't know if you work with legged
robots or a bunch of these
um they they make they sure as heck make
me feel like they're conscious
uh in a certain way that's not here
today but
is um
you could see the kernel yeah it's like
uh
the the the
flame the beginnings of a flame we don't
have line of sight but there's
glimmerings of light in the distance for
all of these things yeah i'm hearing
murmuring in a distant room
you